είπαμε μεγαλύτερι τη οργάνωση που πήναμε ποτεώρα των ερχόμενο αύγουστο θα ζήσουμε στιγμέ καλάθοσσφερικές κάτι
που έχουμε ανάγκη πιο το μήνυμα του αντρέα πριν νακλησουμ αυτό που λέω που λέμε
πάντα από το κιδύο είναι θνική επόθεση του ευρωπάς και του σ δε είναι δουλεια
του ενώς δεν είναι οδυλειά τις όμως πονίας μας και τμόνο είναι θνική υπόθεση και
έτσι πρέπει να το να το να το εκλαμβάνουμε καικαι είμαστε ευλογημένοι που η κεντρική
κυβέρνηση το έχει το έχει καταλάβει και δουλεύει πάνως αυτό ότι είναι θνική πόθεςη τα
οφέλει δεν είναι μόνο για τον πάσκε το φέλει να ιν τόπο μας είναι για
των αθλητομό μόν τουν τόπου μας πρέπει να αναδείξουμε την κύπρο νός αθλητικώ τουρισμό όχι
με των ατο λέμε και όχι με το ναβασιζόμαστε πάνωση ιδιωτικές πρωτοβουλίες ένας μαραθόνιος με
ένας πολύο δηλατικός γύρος που γίνονται και εγίνο η ένα ράλι τα οποία είναι διωτικές
πρωτοβουλίες απλά πρέπει επιτέλους με με αφετιαρίαν το ευροπάς και τουντε που αποδείξαμε ότι μπορούμε
οη μικρή κύπρος και αγωνιστικά και πληθιστημικά και μιςικατεχόμενι ότι μπορούμε θα πρέπει επιτέλους και
βλέπω τ υπάρχει βουλησί να συνεργαστον ροεφιπουργίο ντουρισμού το υπουργιώ οικονομικόν το ειπουργεί ντουρισμού είτε
το υφιπουργειώ αθιλισμού είτε εκόόπως θέλισβαρτό και να γίνει μια σωστή ουσιαστική στρατηγική ου θα
έχει να κάνει με των αθλητικώ τουρισμό στων τόπο μας γιατί είναι κρίμα είναι μια
νέα επιχειρηματική δραστηριότητα να μην το έχουμε και αυτό πουπου απλόχειραν μπορούμε νατο προσφέρω τι
χρειάζεται βελτείωση αθελητικών υπογο υποδμο το σχέδιο που το ίπαμε βελτίω η αθλητικών ογονώ υποδομό
και ώραμαν από αυτούς που ηγούνται του ατων αθελητικώ νομως π εδιώ τίποτα παρπαν χαριστό
παραβολι και εγώ ευχαριστ λέπει τχία να πούμε ότι